oh yeah iconic tv commercials
super soakers and the perfect bite of
your favorite sugary snack
these are just a few things that made
being a kid awesome
and here are the untold stories behind
why and how
they came to be oh yeah
milk good old-fashioned milk in your
cereal in your coffee
in your glass calcium but the best use
for milk
dunking cookies i mean who doesn't love
a cookie dipped in milk
but why turns out it's because science
says so
but before we get into it let's take a
quick look back in time
[Music]
it's 10 000 bce the agricultural
revolution occurs
animals are domesticated and animals are
milked great
a lot of time goes by hey guess what
it's 1862.
louis pasteur modernizes milk safety the
term pasteurizes born
get it maybe no who cares moving on
it's 1884. milk is bottled up the
milkman became a thing yada yada 1994
got milk out swept the nation everyone's
got a milk mustache great
now that's over why the he double hockey
sticks do we dunk our cookies into milk
[Music]
when you dip cookies into milk you
change a number of things about those
cookies that completely
alters your eating experience by alters
matt means oh wait let me introduce you
to matt hi my name is matt hardings
and i am a professor of chemistry and i
teach a class on cooking chemistry
here at american university but back to
it
by alters matte means when you dip
cookies into milk not only does the
texture and flavor
change but the chemical composition does
as well which is what makes scientists
go
wild chemists are fascinated
in how taste works and how all the
molecules that your
experiencing when you're eating food how
they all work together and
lead to one thought in your brain but
how
there are specific ways to measure food
chemistry
things like an ms nose that tries to
break
down food aromas into their individual
parts
the ms nose is a tool that helps
scientists understand how complex
molecules come together to make flavor
[Music]
so what does all this fancy technology
tell us when you dunk that cookie
you add a creaminess to your cookie and
that
makes your your cookie taste completely
different
you will dampen some of the flavors that
are naturally sharp in a chocolate chip
cookie
it will soak up liquids
so we can universally agree dunking
chocolate chip cookies into milk
is the best thing ever speaking to my
own experience
i am not a big dipper wait what
i take a bite of my cookie and then have
a drink of milk
you just had to be different didn't you
still sounds delicious to me
oh yeah i've been making this drink
sound so
attractive and desirable for all these
years do you recognize me
i'm the kool-aid man oh
yeah so i've had several people say it's
hard to picture that that
voice is actually coming from you the
human being
oh yeah they like the voice because they
don't know who i am
when i first auditioned i think they
wanted to get the flavor
of the kool-aid man that was already on
the air oh yeah
when i came in instead of making it oh
oh i wanted to go
down oh oh oh so he's gonna have a big
deep voice so i just thought like this
guy wants to be a oh
yeah cool and i tried to make the voice
you know just kind of roll around
gutterly in my throat
oh yeah i can remember those sessions
after three hours of them just saying
okay do it again do it again do it again
try it again how about lower more energy
more this more very wide bigger bigger
bigger louder louder i'd be saying like
what am i not doing that you're not
getting but you're telling me to use a
lot of high energy like david lee roth i
said the two don't mix david lead ross
going oh
yeah doesn't mix with barry white going
oh
yeah so you have to find a happy balance
there's this amazing picture of my
co-worker it's him
reading a ninja turtles book lying next
to a super soaker
when the super soaker came out it was a
game changer
the slogan wetter is better was
essentially a mantra for kids during
summer break
so when i went to atlanta to interview
the guy responsible for all that
i had to show him the photo
that's funny lonnie johnson
invented the super soaker back in 1982
but that is not his only invention well
i have over 100 patents
everything from the nerf gun to a
thermoelectric energy converter
he also worked on nasa's galileo mission
to jupiter
and alongside the u.s military the first
super soaker actually i made in my
shop in my basement in the evenings when
i would come home from work
and at the time i was actually working
on the stealth department program
back when it was highly classified and i
actually couldn't even tell my wife what
i was working on during the daytime it
was that
that top secret the original name for
the super soaker was
the drencher we ran into a challenge uh
regarding the name because another
inventor claimed it so we changed the
name to super soaker just to avoid
having to
to deal with that super soaker is
definitely a way better name
when he started lonnie wasn't trying to
create a toy for kids
i was working on a new type of heat pump
that would use water
as a working fluid instead of freon and
i was experimenting with
some nozzles that i machined and i shot
a stream of water across the bathroom
and i thought she's
maybe i should put this hard side stuff
aside and
work on something fun like a water gun
it still works and this brings me back
to a previous point
lonnie johnson is a super genius
scientist this is his lab
and this is what he's working on now
right now working on advanced maverick
technology
my goal is to develop a battery that
will store about three times the energy
of a lithium lithium-ion battery
in comparison the super soaker might not
seem as hard science
but it was still a really really
important invention
it's plastic it's most likely beige and
it sounds like this
[Music]
chances are if you grew up in the united
states you've played a recorder
it was a non-negotiable part of your
elementary school education
and for that you can thank this guy carl
orff
a passionate german composer
[Music]
originally the recorder was handcrafted
wooden and made for the highest of
society
even vivaldi and bach wrote pieces for
the recorder
it doesn't rely on a read or strings
just breath
it's in the flute family in the 1960s
the recorder started being produced out
of plastic
cheap plastic so how did it become the
clumsy awkward sound we all used to play
[Music]
that's where orf comes in he saw the
recorder as an easy way to get kids to
start playing music
the logic was simple the recorder relies
on rhythm rather than memorization
if you can sing you most likely can play
it
orff had the best of intentions to
inspire the next generation of musicians
and even though they can sometimes be
annoying our hats are off to you sir
for changing the course of music
education for generations to come
[Music]
[Applause]
hello normally when you think of words
they fit into a language
but there's a relatively new class of
words that don't quite follow the rules
and it's called wasago
[Music]
john kelly is a language writer i spend
a lot of my time writing about
word origins he's a linguistics expert
and he knows just about everything about
the phenomenon called juago
wasse ego literally means japan made
english it is a language process
that takes foreign words uh usually
english words and transmogrifies them
into something wholly new
and novel for japanese purposes
we see this with a word like karaoke
everybody knows and everybody loves
karaoke
but it joins the japanese kara which
means empty
and okay which is a japanese rendering
of orchestra so a karaoke is an empty
orchestra
the most popular example is the word
pokemon the creator of pokemon
took two english words pocket and
monster he smashed them together
and got pokemon or take cosplay
a word that describes people dressing up
as fictional characters cosplay joins
costume and play and there's anime anime
is a fairly straightforward rendering of
the english
animation wassi hugo is important
because language is always changing
and reinventing itself what new words
will pop up in the future
only time will tell
you